the refreshed case for independence is
about how we equip ourselves to navigate
the challenges and fulfill that
potential now and in future
in their day-to-day lives people across
scotland are of course suffering the
impacts of the soaring cost of living
low growth and increasing inequality
constrained public finances and the many
many implications of a brexit that we
did not vote for
these problems have all been made worse
or most obviously in the case of brexit
directly caused by the fact we are not
independent
so at this critical juncture we face a
fundamental question do we stay tied to
a uk economic model that consigns us to
relatively poor economic and social
outcomes which are likely to get worse
not better outside the european union or
do we
instead
lift our eyes with hope and optimism and
take inspiration from comparable
countries across europe
comparable neighbouring countries with
different characteristics countries that
in many cases lack the abundance of
resources that scotland is blessed with
but all of them independent and as we
show today
wealthier and fairer than the uk
today's paper and those that will follow
in the weeks and months to come
is about substance
that is what really matters
the strength of the substantive case
will determine the decision people reach
when the choice is offered as it will be
and it is time now to set out and debate
that case
after
everything that has happened brexit
covered
boris johnson it is time to set out a
different and better vision
it is time to talk about making scotland
wealthier and fairer it is time to talk
about independence and then to make the
choice
now how we secure that choice as we are
committed to doing is of course a highly
pertinent question so while today is
very much about substance let me address
briefly the issue of process
i was re-elected as first minister just
over one year ago on a clear commitment
to give the people of scotland the
choice of becoming an independent
country
and the people of scotland elected a
scottish parliament with a decisive
majority in favour of both independence
and the right to choose
the scottish parliament therefore has an
indisputable democratic mandate and we
intend to honor that
a referendum though if it is to be
deliverable command confidence and
achieve its objective must be lawful
it is the parties opposed to
independence and only them who would
benefit from doubt about the process
these parties don't want to engage on
the substance of this debate because
they know
how increasingly threadbare their
arguments are their only hope is to cast
doubt on the process
those of us who relish the opportunity
to make and win the substantive case for
independence mustn't allow them to do so
of course if this uk government had any
respect at all for democracy the issue
of legality would be put beyond doubt as
in 2014 through a section 30 order i
make clear to the prime minister again
today that i stand ready to discuss the
terms of such an order at any time
but my duty as a democratically elected
first minister is to the people of
scotland it is not to boris johnson or
to any tory prime minister this is a uk
government that has no respect for
democracy and as we saw again yesterday
it has no regard for the rule of law
either
that means if we are to uphold democracy
here in scotland we must forge a way
forward if necessary without a section
30 order for the reasons i've set out
already however we must do so in a
lawful manner
we know that in these circumstances the
competence of the scottish parliament to
legislate is contested
and that therefore is the situation we
must navigate to give people the choice
of independence now that work is well
underway and while i do not intend to go
further into the detail today i can say
that i do plan to give a significant
update to parliament very soon indeed
the principles of democracy and the rule
of law are fundamental
they should unite all of us regardless
of our politics indeed democracy within
the rule of law is how differences of
political or constitutional opinion
should always be resolved
the fact that these principles are now
so deeply disrespected and disregarded
day and daily in the uk is itself an
indication of how broken westminster
governance is
indeed that has become part of the
argument for independence and it is to
that substantive case that i now return
the choice people arrive at on
independence must be an informed one the
case we make must speak not just to
those who already support independence
but also
indeed even more so to those not yet
persuaded
it is an obvious point but one that i
think always bears repetition scotland
will only become independent when a
majority of those who live here vote for
it
it is in that spirit therefore that we
publish this first in the building a new
scotland series of papers today we set
the scene
i can confirm though that papers to come
later in the series and which are
already in preparation will include the
issues of currency
scotland's fiscal position and how with
independence we can build a more
sustainable economy and therefore
stronger public finances pensions and
social security eu membership and trade
defence and security in these papers we
will set out how scotland can benefit
from the opportunities the massive
opportunities that independents will
present
we will also confront openly the
challenges we will not shy away from
tough questions we will address key
issues relating to the transition from a
yes vote to independence and the
infrastructure that will be required for
the governance of an independent country
of course on that latter point scotland
has already come a long way since 2014 a
great deal of nation building has been
done in the years since for example
scotland now has our own tax and social
security agencies an independent fiscal
commission and a national investment
bank in other words substantial parts of
the infrastructure that an independent
scotland will need and which did not
exist in 2014 are now in place that
means scotland today is even more
prepared for independence than we were
in 2014.
of course any case for change starts
with an analysis of the status quo and
that is the purpose of the paper we are
publishing today
it really isn't difficult to list the
many ways in which westminster
governance is currently failing scotland
and holding us back
we have a prime minister with no
democratic authority in scotland and no
moral authority anywhere in the uk
brexit has ripped us out of the eu and
the single market against our will with
massive damage to trade living standards
and public services thanks to brexit the
cost of living crisis is worse here in
the uk than in any other g7 country
inflation in the uk is double that of
france
uk growth is now projected by the oecd
to be the second lowest in the g20 next
year
only sanctioned russia will be worse
the end of freedom of movement has left
our businesses and public services
struggling for workers it has also
robbed young people of opportunity
and to compound all of that we face the
very real risk now of an eu trade war
due to the uk government's threat to
breach international law over the
northern ireland protocol
this is the very same uk government that
negotiated and signed the protocol a
protocol that is actually delivering
significant economic benefits to
northern ireland only adds to the
absurdity
in short the case for scotland charting
our own course a better course is strong
and compelling
but the evidence we set out today shows
that this case does not just rest on
recent or temporary developments
in today's paper we look in detail at 10
competitor countries ireland switzerland
norway denmark the netherlands iceland
sweden austria belgium and finland
the evidence is overwhelming that these
countries now and over time perform
better than the uk
compared to these countries many of them
smaller or similarly sized to us
scotland under westminster control is
being held back
with independence we too would have the
levers and the autonomy that these
countries take for granted
to help fulfill their potential and
let's look at the evidence presented
today
every single one of these competitor
countries is wealthier than the uk and
that wealth gap has been maintained over
the long term
all of these countries have greater
income equality than the uk
poverty rates are lower in every single
one of them with fewer children living
in poverty most of them have a smaller
gender pay gap all of them have higher
social mobility
and they have more productive and
innovative economies too
all of them have higher productivity
most of them spend more on research and
development business investment is
higher too
the evidence set out in this paper is
clear and it is unambiguous all of these
countries all of them are wealthier
fairer and more productive than the uk
and all of these countries all of them
are independent
so as we look to the future the great
question before us is this if all of
these countries can and do use the
powers of independence to create
wealthier and fairer societies why not
scotland with our vast energy resources
why not scotland with our globally
recognized
record of innovation invention and
learning why not scotland with our
exceptional food and drink industry
extraordinary natural heritage and the
strength we have in advanced engineering
and a range of cutting-edge industries
of the future why not scotland above all
with the talent and the potential of all
of the people who live here why not
scotland
now independence
does not guarantee success for any
country and we should never pretend that
it does but for scotland independence
will put the levers that determine
success into our own hands it will mean
we can work in partnership with our
friends and the rest of the uk
but not be subject to decisions of
westminster governments we don't vote
for and which are taking us in the wrong
direction
it will give us the ability just like
these competitor countries to fulfill
the vast potential we have and build the
wealthier fairer happier country we know
is possible
that then is the prize building a better
nation now and for the future that
indeed is the whole purpose of
independence
grasping that prize will not be without
challenge
nothing worth doing ever is so in the
months ahead we will set out in detail
how we can make the transition to
independence how we can navigate and
overcome these challenges so that this
precious prize the opportunity of a
better country can be won
scotland now and for the generations
that come after us deserves the very
best and independence is how we can
secure that